hey hola cómo estás voy a ver el
problema número 9 que me parece bastante
interesante fíjate tenemos una figura
muy grande por aquí y en esta figura me
dan que la distancia de adén es 1 y
además me dan que la distancia de de ac
es la raíz cuadrada de 3 y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale z
entonces fíjate bien en este dibujo tan
peculiar si te das cuenta aquí tenemos
dos triángulos rectángulos este es un
triángulo rectángulo y este otro es un
triángulo rectángulo y además me dicen
que estos dos ángulos miden lo mismo si
dos ángulos miden lo mismo es más déjeme
apuntarlo por aquí si yo tengo un
triángulo más o menos así como éste algo
así como éste y algo como por acá y yo
sé que este ángulo y este ángulo miden
lo mismo entonces este lado y este lado
deben de medir lo mismo son propiedades
de triángulos
acuerdo bien qué propiedades que
comparten una base y que tienen dos
ángulos iguales y los lados son iguales
ángulo ángulo lado lado no recuerdo bien
pero está en la sección de geometría tú
puedes verificar qué pasa con este tipo
de triángulos y es que esto me va a
servir porque entonces si este ángulo y
este ángulo son iguales entonces este
lado y este lado deben de ser iguales
por lo tanto este lado debe de medir uno
es justo lo que tenemos en este dibujito
de aquí y ahora que tengo que este lado
mide uno y bueno también podrías
entretenerte sacando la hipotenusa
diciendo que es la raíz de uno más uno
es decir raíz de dos o sacar estos dos
ángulos que como sonámbulos iguales cada
uno debe de medir 45 pero realmente lo
que queremos es z y para sacar z quiero
que te fijes en este 1 y en esta raíz de
3 ahora si ves este triángulo donde
estoy pasando mi puntero justo en él
quiero que te fijes muy bien en él
porque hay algo interesante pasando por
aquí para
quiero recordar una propiedad de los
triángulos 30 60 90 y si recuerdas bien
a los tramos los 30 60 90 no creo que
tengas problema en resolver este dibujo
de una manera muy sencilla este dato
está en la página 423 así que si no lo
recuerdas puedes regresar a esa página y
repasarlo en la pagina 423 nos dicen lo
siguiente si yo tengo un triángulo más o
menos así y entonces esto está así
no me gustó a ver mejor esto está así y
después tengo algo por acá y este
triángulo es un triángulo 30 60 90 es
decir este ángulo va a medir 30 grados
este de aquí va a medir 60 grados y
bueno es un triángulo rectángulo
entonces cualquier triángulo que cumpla
esta propiedad si este lado mide x este
otro lado va a medir raíz de 3
x en todos los triángulos 30 60 90 pasan
esta propiedad y espero que en este
momento ya te esté saltando algo con
este mismo triángulo porque aquí tengo
uno aquí tengo raíz de 3 por 1 y por lo
tanto este triángulo de aquí debe ser un
triángulo 30 60 90 es decir que este
lado debe de estar asociado con un
ángulo de 30 grados es decir que z vale
30 grados y este otro lado el que vale 1
debe estar asociado con este ángulo que
mide 60 grados y si lo que queríamos
saber era el valor de z
de esta manera muy fácilmente podemos
encontrar su valor y ahora sí ya no
podemos poner z vale 30 grados y esto me
hace sentir muy feliz como para moverme
al problema número 10 así que voy a
borrar toda esta figura y bueno espero
no haberse confundido mucho si realmente
se te hizo muy difícil el problema
pasado entonces recuerda un poco los
triángulos 30 60 90 que por cierto están
en la página 423
de este libro es arte pero bueno vamos a
hacer el problema número 10 y el
problema número 10 dice lo siguiente el
30 por ciento del 40 por ciento de un
cierto número y el 30 por ciento del 40
por ciento vamos a juntarlo el 30 por
ciento del 40 por ciento del 40 por
ciento de un cierto número entonces
vamos a suponer de x esto es igual al 20
por ciento del w por ciento de ese mismo
número al 20 por ciento de w por ciento
de ese mismo número de equis y bueno lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale w yo lo
que quiero saber es cuánto vale w
así que vamos a escribir esto y se me
ocurre en su forma decimal el 30 por
ciento es 0.30 o punto 30
ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por el 40%
cuando yo digo el 30 por ciento del 40
por ciento estoy pensando en el 30 por
ciento por el 40 por ciento de este
mismo número que se llama x es decir por
equis y esto tiene que ser igual al 20%
del w por ciento de x o dicho de otra
manera esto es punto 20 por w vamos a
ponerlo así por w por x en lugar de
dividir a w entre 100 al final mejor lo
multiplicó por 100 y qué creés de aquí
puedo cancelar a x voy a cancelar a esta
x de aquí a esta x de acá y me queda
punto 30 por punto 40 lo cual es punto
12 3 por 4 es 12 y recorro el punto
decimal dos veces punto 12 es igual a
punto 2 por w apuntó 20 por w y de aquí
ya puedo despejar el w de una manera muy
sencilla w es igual
12 en 3.2 y si de aquí recorre el punto
decimal esto me va a quedar punto 6 o
dicho de otra manera si quiero ver a w
como un porcentaje puedo decir que w es
el 60% y tiene todo el sentido lógico
del mundo el 30% del 40% de x es el 20%
del 60% de x o de hecho esto también lo
podríamos resolver de la siguiente
manera esto mismo lo podemos pensar y
creo que se vería más fácil así si este
problema logramos resuelto como el 30
por ciento pero el 30 por ciento es lo
mismo que 30 sobre 100 del 40 por ciento
del recuerda que es por del 40 por
ciento es decir el 40 por ciento sobre
el 100 por ciento de un cierto número es
decir por x esto va a ser igual al 20
por ciento que es el 20 entre 100 de w
por ciento es decir
w entre 100 entre 100 es otra forma de
resolverlo por equis y podremos pensarlo
de una manera muy parecida aquí
cancelaríamos a equis y los padres que
también cancelaríamos este 100 este
siguen estos siguen y está 100 porque
estoy dividiendo entre 100 todo de tal
manera que me quedaría 30 por 40 esto es
igual a 20 por w y de aquí despejando w
me va a quedar que el w es igual a 30
por 40 entre 20 canceló este con este y
me va a quedar que w
es igual a 60 a un 60 por ciento
bueno aquí hay dos formas de resolver
este mismo problema creo que esta forma
era más fácil y esencialmente en un
principio pensé en resolverlo por esta
manera pero quién sabe por qué llegué a
esta ecuación y bueno para esto
este problema tiene como solución el
inciso b entonces déjame apuntarlo aquí
presionan es lo mismo y ya tenemos aquí
la respuesta del problema número 10 así
que vamos a ir
el problema siguiente problema número 11
el problema número 11 que me dice y
bueno
noticia de último momento como tú sabes
resuelvo estos problemas en tiempo real
y por lo tanto me encuentro con
dificultades para saber cuál es el
procedimiento óptimo para resolver estos
problemas fue por eso que resolvía el
problema pasado de dos maneras distintas
y después me di cuenta que la segunda
forma de resolverlo era la forma más
fácil sin embargo creo que es mucho
mejor que te des cuenta en este vídeo
cómo resuelvo yo estos problemas y que
veas qué línea o qué procedimiento sigo
para resolver este problema y además con
que hay dificultades me encuentro para
así llegar a la solución creo que es
mucho mejor que lo veas desde una
perspectiva mucho más humana a que te
encuentres una fría presentación de cómo
resuelves un problema creo que te va a
servir más que veas cómo resuelvo yo
este tipo de problemas
así que por cierto vamos a resolver el
problema número 11
está genial porque tiene una figura muy
padre fíjate bien tenemos como
rectángulos anidados así que déjame ser
un rectángulo por aquí tengo la
herramienta perfecta para ello tengo
este rectángulo de aquí y después a la
mitad voy a decir que por aquí es la
mitad tengo otro rectángulo otro
rectángulo por acá y después a la mitad
tengo otro rectángulo otro 20 modo por
acá y después a la mitad de esta mitad
tengo otro rectángulo uno parecido a
este muy bien y después tengo otro
rectángulo voy a poner otro rectángulo
por acá muy bien y para finalizar tengo
otros rectángulos por aquí y otros más
por acá perfecto y de hecho está
coloreado el último rectángulo así que
déjame colorearlo este tiene un color
blanco vamos a suponer y bueno el
problema dice lo siguiente en la figura
siguiente el rectángulo
cd este es am este es ven este es el y
este es de en la figura siguiente el
rectángulo a veces está formado por
siete rectángulos que no se superponen
los dos rectángulos pequeños tienen la
misma área así que estos dos tienen la
misma área y cada uno de los rectángulos
tiene el doble de área que el rectángulo
que la antecede en área es decir que
este rectángulo tiene el doble de área
que este rectángulo y me preguntan qué
fracción representa el área del
rectángulo pequeño a comparación del
área del rectángulo y bsd es decir yo
quiero ver en cuanto crecimos de este
rectángulo pequeño a este rectángulo a
bs de y bueno qué tal si suponemos que
el área de este rectángulo pequeño es x
así que vamos a ponerlo esto no es pero
todavía sigo utilizando la herramienta
de rectángulos mejor déjenme cambiar la
pluma y ahora si voy a decir que esta
área es
este color está muy claro así que
déjenme tomar otro color esta área es
equis y entonces como estos dos
rectángulos tienen la misma área
entonces esta área también es equis y
ahora si nosotros comparamos este
rectángulo pequeño con este rectángulo
que le sigue en área entonces es el
doble porque habíamos dicho que cada uno
de los rectángulos tiene el doble de
área que el rectángulo que los antecede
por lo tanto si el área de este
rectángulo es x entonces esta área es 2x
y para acá pues sería el doble el doble
de 2 x es 4x y para acá pues sería el
doble y el doble de 4x es 8x así que
este rectángulo tiene como área 8x y
para arriba tengo que sacar el doble de
8 x es decir multiplicar por 2 a 8x que
es 16 x y si nos vamos para acá bueno
pues este rectángulo va a tener 32 veces
el área del pequeño 32 x es decir el
doble
y si nosotros nos fijamos en todo el
rectángulo abs de el rectángulo abc de
completo tendría una área de 64 x así
que si comparamos el área del rectángulo
psd con el área de este rectángulo
pequeño en una fracción nos vamos a dar
cuenta que el quebrado que representaría
sería x entre 64 x es decir que este
rectángulo grandote es 64 veces en área
el área de este pequeño rectángulo y
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 1 sobre
64 y ahí está la respuesta así que
espero que hayas entendido este problema
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo